hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an Indian thriller film
called table number 21 spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie kicks off as an unnamed man
commits the unthinkable from the top of
a building damn table number 21 not
messing around surprisingly a camera is
seen recording him and millions of
people are watching him online it
appears as if he was a part of the
notorious red room that is only found on
the dark web following this we are
introduced to a young couple Vivan and
Sia who are on their way to Fiji on a
business class flight they will be
spending a week in a luxurious five-star
resort with the most lavish of
Arrangements money can buy but
surprisingly from the couple's
conversation we get to know that both of
them are unemployed and have been
looking for jobs desperately now the
question arises how are they affording
such an expensive vacation well it turns
out that they participated in a lottery
and won the first prize which is a paid
trip to Fiji in the next scene the
couple arrives at Fiji and they are
escorted to their hotel it is a
beautiful place that is surrounded by
Lush Greenery and blue Seas Vivan and
Sia are over the moon to have been
selected for such an exotic opportunity
hence for the first few days they spend
their time eating making love and even
busting out a few Bollywood numbers from
time to time vivon also checks his email
to see if he has received any job offers
but every time he is left disappointed
in this way five days pass by in a jiffy
but on the sixth the room service guy
arrives at their door with a bouquet of
flowers he asks them to get dressed and
come to the dining room saying we have
something special for you it turns out
today is the couple's 10th anniversary
vivon is shocked as to how the resort
guys knew about it since he probably
almost forgot about it himself but Sia
doesn't think much of it and asks him to
get ready after a while the couple puts
on their fancy suits and reaches the
dining area where they are greeted with
traditional music there is also a lovely
cake and some wine put in front of them
seeing all of this vivon gets emotional
and starts ranting that his useless life
Vivan you're killing the vibe buddy
however he promises to give Sia all the
happiness and the luxuries that she
deserves his emotional Outburst is
interrupted when a shady looking man
approaches them from behind he is Mr
Khan the manager of the resort and the
one who invited the couple here he
immediately wins the couple's trust by
cracking some corny jokes and then takes
them to the bar for a few drinks there
Mr Khan reveals that the resort is
famous for hosting a bi-monthly game
called table number 21 in which only
married couples can participate the game
will be live telecasted into a large
number of audience members across the
world he then asks vivon and Sia if they
would like to try it out the rules are
very simple Mr Khan will ask them a set
of eight yes or no questions which will
be related to their personal lives after
each question they will be given a
particular task the second rule is that
once they participate they cannot
abandon the game in the middle and the
final rule is that they cannot use the
bathroom or no that's wrong they cannot
use the assistance of an outsider Mr
Khan also reiterates the phrase if you
lie you will die vivon is intrigued by
the weird game and being fires if
there's any reward if they win to their
shock Mr Khan reveals that it is 21
crore rupees sorry if I butchered that I
don't know what a crore is hence without
any hesitation the couple accepts the
challenge I guess crore is awesome as
they are sure Mr Khan doesn't know much
about their personal lives they also
believe that it is the perfect
opportunity to earn some cash and sort
out their miserable lives following this
the couple is brought to another room
where they are made to sign some
agreement papers they are also strapped
with a lie detector bracelet that grows
red and green when someone is lying or
telling the truth respectively then
several cameras are fitted in the room
and Mr Khan reveals that about 6 million
people in the world will be watching
this makes the couple a bit nervous
however after a small chat they're ready
to go for the first question Mr Khan
asks Vivan if he is comfortable making
out with his wife in public the latter
says no and his bracelet turns green Mr
Khan congratulates them and asks them to
make out in the busiest Street in the
city this is the second part of the task
and if they success successfully
completed they will win one crore rupees
unsurprisingly the couple does it
without any hesitation when they return
back to the resort vivon complains that
the task was too easy he believes that
everything is a joke and that there is
no reward for winning it in reply Mr
Khan opens a room which is stacked with
a shitload of cash at the same time
vivon checks his phone and learns that
one crore rupees has already been
credited to his account this elates the
couple and they get ready to face off
the remaining challenges for the second
question Mr Khan asks Sia if she
believes her husband knows her well she
replies with a firm no which turns out
to be the correct answer Vivan is
slightly annoyed as he thought he knew
everything about his wife after this Sia
is asked to complete a task she will
have to consume a dish which is made up
of cooked insects vivon who knows that
his wife is a vegetarian becomes scared
that they will lose the challenge and
ultimately the prize money but to his
surprise Sia begins munching on the
insects hence winning two crore rupees
for them this proves that vivon in fact
doesn't know much about Sia or maybe
those bugs were made out of plants in
the third question Mr Khan challenges
vivon to manipulate him in any way the
latter being a smart guy does it
effortlessly however it is evident that
Mr Khan wanted them to proceed to the
next stage in the fourth question he
asks Vivan if he can do anything to save
his wife the latter says yes and his
bracelet glows green as for the task Sia
is locked in an airtight chamber which
has a limited amount of oxygen there is
only one way for vivon to get her out he
will have to draw 500 milliliters of his
own blood this shocks Vivan as he has
always been scared of blood vivon pleads
with Mr Khan that he cannot complete the
challenge and that they simply want to
go home Manny's caving fast at this
point he doesn't even care about the
money however Mr Khan makes it clear
that the timer has already started so
stop being a [__] of Yvonne in the next
seven minutes the oxygen inside the
chamber will run out and Sia will
suffocate to death hearing this vivon
mans up and gets is ready to face his
worst phobia he somehow gathers some
courage and manages to draw out the
required amount of blood hence freeing
his wife after the narrow escape the
couple realizes that the questions and
tasks that they are being given are not
ordinary after all Mr Khan already knew
about their weaknesses like Sia hates
non-vegetarian food and Vivan is scared
of blood hence they decide to abandon
the game and head back to the airport
the couple gets on a boat and tries to
get away but after a while the bracelets
on their hands start beeping then Mr
Khan talks through the boat's speaker
revealing that if they try to violate
the second rule of table number 21 I.E
abandoning the game the bracelets in
their hands will explode and kill them
hearing this the couple reluctantly
heads back to the resort now it's time
for the fifth question Mr Khan asks
Vivan if he will love his wife the same
even if she goes bald vivon replies with
a resounding yes and the lie detector
turns green much to the relief of SIA
however when she hears the task she is
almost brought to tears the Yvonne is
ordered to shave her hair and make her
bald right now this obviously doesn't
sit well with SIA and she pleads with
her husband to not go through with it
however with Victory very close vivon
doesn't want to take any chances so he
calms her down grabs the trimmer and
makes her look like one punch man now
the couple has won five crore rupees in
the sixth question it is vivon's turn
yet again he is asked if he has Ever
Raised hands on his wife with this the
movie goes into a flashback Sia has just
gotten an abortion because of their weak
economic condition Jesus got dark she
believes that they won't be able to
raise their baby in a proper way however
vivon thinks otherwise he is angry that
this decision was made without his
consultation so in a fit of rage he
smacks his wife back in the present
vivon hesitantly says yes and the
bracelet glows green for the task Mr
Khan brings out a sound meter which has
a scale up to 120 decibels he then asks
Sia to slap her husband as hard as she
can and reach the end limit of the sound
meter Sia doesn't want to hit her
innocent husband for no reason but since
their lives are on the line she has to
do it she starts off with a few soft
slaps slaps that would bring shame to
moist critical but then she does some
hard ones ultimately she manages to hit
120 decibels on the sound meter at the
expense of her husband's cheeks at this
point the couple have started regretting
their arrival in Fiji they wish that
they had never won the lottery
nonetheless they get ready for the sixth
question and Mr Khan asks vivon if he
has ever assaulted someone he answers
with a yes which is true because Vivan
was a hardcore bully at school best get
them cheeks ready for some more clapping
following this Mr Khan hands him a
hockey stick and orders him to vandalize
a certain car parked outside the car
belongs to someone who is not a part of
the game reluctantly vivon heads outside
and begins smashing the car as if it
belongs to his ex-girlfriend but as he
is about to leave the owners of the car
arrive and Tackle him to the ground
vivon somehow runs away and meets a cop
he then discloses everything including
how they're being forced to play a
deadly game that is being broadcasted
across the world however before you can
give out more details Mr Khan's men
arrive and take him away in their car
once they return to the resort Mr Khan
chastises vivon for breaking the third
rule he tried to interact with an
outsider the cop so as a punishment Sia
has been taken to a club dressed as an
escort Mr Khan further explains that she
has been tied to a pole and one by one
her clothes are being stripped the whole
thing is being broadcast live on
television Mr Khan then hands vivon the
club's address telling him to save his
wife if he can wasting no Time vivon
Rushes to the place and arrives in the
nick of time as Sia is about to be
stripped of her last clothes he then
fights off a macho guy and eventually
frees his wife after returning to the
resort the couple begs to be let go but
Mr Khan says that it's not possible
instead he starts revealing the
specifics of table number 21 it turns
out that Vivan and Sia weren't chosen
randomly in fact a very thorough
research was conducted on their lives
because they were struggling financially
and had a lot of secrets between them
they were chosen as the winners and
given an all-paid vacation to the resort
Mr Khan then apologizes for the
inconvenience but asserts that it is
just business he then asks them to get
ready for the final question if they win
they will be 21 crores richer in the
next scene Mr Khan starts briefing about
the final challenge since it is the
finale eight rapid fire questions will
be asked each is worth two crores at the
end of it they will be given one single
task the catch is that they will have to
answer each question incorrectly Sia is
chosen for it she doesn't want to go
through with it but vivon reminds her
that they have no other choice soon the
game begins and Mr Khan starts
bombarding Sia with rapid fire questions
she answers seven of them correctly and
it all goes down to the final question
to the couple's horror Mr Khan asks if
she has ever slept with another man Even
after their marriage Sia who has to give
the wrong answer hesitant says yes and
surprisingly the bracelet turns green
this reveals that she did have an
extramarital affair vivon's expression
suddenly changes and Sia starts
screaming that the machine is lying
however Mr Khan clears everything by a
simple trick he takes Sia's phone and
texts her boss who she supposedly had
coitus with to vivon's dismayed the boss
replies in a very seductive manner
indicating that his wife did cheat on
him finally Sia comes clean that at the
time she was about to be fired and the
only way to convince her boss was by
doing it now that the game is over Mr
Khan brings out a gun and says that Sia
will have to die because she has spoken
a lie vivon despite having his heart
broken does not want to see the love of
his life pass away hence he pleads with
Mr Khan to find an alternative in the
latter gives them an option if Sia is to
be saved vivon will have to take the
life of another person of his choosing
the courageous husband immediately
accepts The Proposal after this the
couple is escorted inside a room where a
mentally stable man is present he is the
Target that has to be killed vivon goes
near him with a gun and gets shocked to
learn that it is Akram his friend from
high school here we get to know that
Akram was mercilessly bullied by vivon
SIA and their friends during High School
The Bullying left such a deep scar in
his mind that he is still not recovered
from it this devastates Vivan and he
hesitates to pull the trigger when Mr
Khan threatens to kill his wife vivon
attempts to commit the unthinkable but
to his surprise there's no bullets in
the gun that's lucky if he'd off himself
his wife probably still would have died
idiot finally Mr Khan reveals that Akram
is his son and he did all of this to get
back at the bullies
okay now that Vivan and Sia have learned
their lessons they are free to go the
movie ends as the couple returns to
their hotel room and contemplates their
life choices Mr Khan has broken them
from the inside and it is evident that
they will never be the same again
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching